[Música]
Hola soy Natalia Cabrera parada y les
doy la bienvenida aquí a América este es
el magazine de France 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente y esto es lo que
veremos hoy
Brasil se divide en dos el presidente de
ultraderecha Yair bolsonaro se enfrenta
en las urnas a la izquierda expresidente
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva en la segunda
vuelta de las elecciones presidenciales
156 millones de brasileños están
llamados a las urnas este domingo pero
sin importar quién llegue al palacio de
plan alto el primero de enero de 2023 lo
que ha quedado claro tras estos cuatro
años de gobierno y la primera vuelta es
que el bolsonarismo es más grande que el
propio bolsonaro y que ha llegado para
quedarse nos cuenta de nuestro equipo en
Río de Janeiro
y Estados Unidos también va a las urnas
pero el 8 de noviembre para las
elecciones de mitad de mandato es decir
que el presidente Joe biden lleva la
mitad de sus primeros cuatro años en la
casa blanca y que son tradicionalmente
vistos como un referendo a la gestión
del mandatario el fenómeno de la
inflación que se vive a nivel global se
convirtió en un tema clave para los
votantes y les explicamos por qué
vamos a Brasil donde el cara a cara
entre el actual presidente de
ultraderecha Yair bolsonaro y el ex
presidente de izquierda Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva tiene lugar este domingo
bolsonaro un escéptico de la pandemia y
a quien a menudo se le llama el Trump
sudamericano acusa a Lula de haber
liderado el gobierno más corrupto de la
historia del país
Lula dejó el cargo en 2010 con un índice
de aprobación del 80%. antes de ser
encarcelado por corrupción una condena
que luego anuló la Corte Suprema de
Justicia el exmandatario por su parte
acusa a bolsonaro de destruir el país
quien sea que seguramente como el
próximo presidente en enero enfrentará
los mismos retos que les explicamos en
el siguiente informe que preparamos para
ustedes
dos hombres con visiones diametralmente
diferentes para su país el izquierdista
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva salió del
Palacio de plan alto en 2010 como el
presidente más popular de la historia de
Brasil Aunque su reputación se vio
manchada después por acusaciones de
corrupción sigue siendo recordado como
el líder que sacó a millones de personas
de la pobreza Brasil enfrenta niveles de
hambruna no vistos en 30 años por lo que
Lula está prometiendo llevar al país de
regreso a ese período un país
que es un país que la gente extraña un
país con trabajo un país donde la gente
tenía derecho a vivir con dignidad con
la cabeza en alto y este país volverá
Lula ha prometido reformar el sistema
tributario para poner la carga
impositiva sobre los más ricos y obtener
un mayor presupuesto Estatal políticas
económicas que son Exactamente lo
contrario de las del actual mandatario
Yair bolsonaro que apoya una plataforma
neoliberal de mayor privatización y se
negó a cerrar la economía de Brasil
durante la pandemia del coronavirus lo
que provocó millones de miles de muertes
bolsonaro ha tratado de ganarse a los
votantes de escasos recursos Con dinero
en efectivo mientras pinta a Lula como
un comunista corrupto
sabemos que el comunismo conduce a la
desgracia la pobreza el hambre y la
miseria no queremos eso para nuestro
Brasil Aunque veamos eso
Los Seguidores del líder de extrema
derecha son en su mayoría fanático
religiosos Defensores del porte de armas
así como de la industria agrícola los
agricultores aprecian su eliminación de
la protección de los territorios
indígenas mientras que los evangélicos
se sienten atraídos por su Campaña
centrada en la defensa de la familia
tradicional bolsonaro a estado sembrando
dudas sin fundamento sobre el sistema de
votación electrónico de Brasil lo que
genera temores de que se negaría a
aceptar la derrota sus críticos ahora
dicen que la democracia está en juego
deberíamos trabajar para ganar el voto
de todos los que aman la democracia
bolsonaru Un capitán retirado del
ejército buscó el respaldo de los
militares para sus afirmaciones
infundadas de fraude electoral e instó a
sus seguidores a armarse desde que
relajó las leyes de arma de fuego de
Brasil 2019 la posición de armas se ha
disparado
y tenemos que luchar contra La Pandilla
de Lula lucharemos y repito el pueblo
armado jamás será esclavizado
la violencia política no es nueva en
Brasil el propio evolucionario fue
apuñalado en la campaña electoral de
2018 pero esta campaña ha estado marcada
por incidentes violentos con varios
simpatizantes de Lula heridos y un
funcionario asesinado por simpatizantes
de bolsonaro los mismos candidatos han
estado usando chalecos antibalas en
público según una encuesta reciente casi
el 70% de los brasileños dicen que temen
ser agredidos físicamente debido a su
afiliación política pero sin importar
quién llegue al palacio de plan alto el
primero de enero de 2023 lo que ha
quedado claro es que el bolsonarismo es
más grande que el propio bolsonaro y que
ha llegado para quedarse muchos
analistas creyeron que el expresidente
Lula podría ganar las elecciones en
primera vuelta porque los sondeos así lo
mostraban sin embargo bolsonaro
consiguió más de 51 millones de
sufragios más del 43% de los votos
veamos el informe de nuestros
corresponsales en Río de Janeiro
Durante los últimos cuatro años los
medios de comunicación han destacado la
faceta más radical delvolucionarismo sin
embargo la mayoría de los electores de
bolsonaro tienen un perfil de
conservador moderado
[Aplausos]
Nosotros siempre tuvimos en nuestra
nación presidentes corruptos y ladrones
y él arrancó este tumor maligno este
cáncer diabólico nuestro presidente
rescató todo eso él dio dignidad a la
familia
reencontramos a Samuel en bambú un
barrio de la periferia de Río de Janeiro
ambos se sienten muy identificados con
la bandera que levanta diario bolsonaro
contra la legalización del aborto y de
las drogas y contra la llamada ideología
de género
yo estoy contra el aborto desde el
momento de la concepción de la Unión de
dos personas Aunque ocurra una fatalidad
todo es permiso de Dios
Samuel que además de agente inmobiliario
también es pastor evangélico valoriza el
respeto que el mandatario hacia la
religión
bolsonaro reconoce que el señor es Dios
cuando bolsonaro llega a una iglesia él
es abrazo las personas quieren abrazar a
bolsonaro y no es solo en la iglesia
evangélica él también va a las iglesias
católicas católica cuatro veces por
semana Samuel y Selma acuden a esta
iglesia evangélica para orar junto a
otros fieles en Brasil el 31% de la
población se declara evangélica cerca de
70 millones de personas
[Música]
los resultados de las elecciones
demostraron que los sondeos subestimaron
la fuerza de este Movimiento Político
cada vez más politólogos se reconocen
que el bolsonarismo perdurará en el
tiempo
bolsonaro consiguió hacer una
conciliación entre estas fuerzas
conservadoras Hay personas con un perfil
más liberal personas de derecha con un
perfil más ligado a la agenda
conservadora en el campo social él
consiguió centralizar todos estos apoyos
el profundo rechazo de un sector de la
sociedad hacia el partido de los
trabajadores ha sido decisivo para la
consolidación del personal
y nos vamos a Estados Unidos que también
va a las urnas pero el 8 de noviembre
para las elecciones de mitad de mandato
que tradicionalmente son vistas como un
referendo a la gestión del mandatario en
este caso de Joe biden están en juego la
totalidad de las sillas de la cámara de
representantes y un tercio de las del
senado y los demócratas el partido al
que pertenece el presidente podrían
perder sus mayorías en el congreso según
un portal que se dedica a comparar
encuestas Navigator public tracking pool
un 20% de los votantes podría darle su
apoyo al partido republicano en
respuesta a los elevados precios de la
gasolina y en general al Estado de la
economía esto es importante considerando
que en varios estados ya comenzó la
votación anticipada veamos más en el
siguiente informe que preparamos para
ustedes
[Música]
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden comparó los planes económicos de
los republicanos con el mini presupuesto
de la ex primera ministra británica Luis
stras que le costó el cargo en el Reino
Unido tras introdujo un recorte de
impuestos para los más ricos lo que
desató la agitación en los mercados
financieros y el rechazo dentro de su
propio partido por lo que se vio
obligada a renunciar
algunos republicanos en la cámara de
representantes se comprometieron a
mantener los recortes de impuestos
introducidos bajo la administración de
Donald Trump vader se ha vuelto a
centrar en la economía en los últimos
días ya que el apoyo a los demócratas ha
disminuido en los días previos a las
elecciones debido a la inflación que
según la oficina de estadísticas
laborales estadounidenses alcanzó el
8,2% en septiembre y los ciudadanos son
las principales víctimas
debo ser honesta por Dios y de quiere
decir que la administración de biden ha
estado jugando con el dinero en la
cámara
nunca he visto a nadie tirar miles de
millones de dólares en otro país
y no es su dinero para hacerlo y
realmente está hirviendo la economía
entiendo que hay una guerra y eso pero
tenemos que pensar en nuestra gente
primero antes de enviar miles de miles
de millones de dólares a un
pozos vi una gran diferencia en la
economía cuando nuestro ex presidente
estaba en la casa blanca los precios de
la gasolina disminuyeron el precio de la
comida estaba bien los estantes estaban
llenos de cosas en las tiendas el
presidente biden también intentó
controlar el pánico y afirmó que las
cosas cambiarían antes de la cita
electoral
estamos en mejor posición que cualquier
otro país del mundo y podemos atravesar
este periodo difícil la inflación Está
peor en todo el mundo ha sido unida y
regreso con ellos adelante nosotros
adelante ellos adelante de ida y regreso
y las encuestas han estado por todos
lados lo que vamos a ver un cambio hacia
nuestro lado en los últimos días
vaiden también protege el derecho a la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo a
nivel Federal si los demócratas
mantienen la mayoría en el congreso
quien controla el legislativo marcará
los siguientes dos años de su estadía en
la casa blanca a diferencia del senado
donde carreras de alto perfil decidirán
el control la próxima la mayoría de la
cámara de representantes se armará como
un rompecabezas el Día de las elecciones
debido a la redistribución de distritos
y las respectivas preocupaciones
regionales sin embargo es casi seguro
que el partido republicano obtendrá al
menos algunos de los cinco escaños que
necesita para controlar el congreso a
través de nuevas líneas distritales
[Música]
y me despido desde México donde
activistas Defensores de la diversidad y
la inclusión celebraron un desfile de
modas para personas con discapacidad con
el fin de promover la aceptación para
ellos en el país
el evento incluyó a 25 modelos la
mayoría con alguna discapacidad que
caminaron por la pasarela con varios
outfits de diseñadores mexicanos
cambiando modelos Espera que el show
ayude a cumplir con el objetivo de
sensibilizar a los mexicanos donde más
del 7% de la población tiene alguna
discapacidad según la Organización
Mundial de la Salud y la mayoría termina
en la pobreza debido a la falta de
educación de oportunidades laborales y
acceso a los servicios de salud gracias
por acompañarme en esta emisión de aquí
América por favor envíenme sus
comentarios en redes sociales a la
dirección que ven en su pantalla en la
producción estuvo Luis Fernando Montes
pueden ver esta emisión y las anteriores
en nuestra página web France 24.com
[Música]